البدايه مع قصه داعش لليوم والزعيم الرابع
لتنظيم داعش الذي لقي مصرعه بحسب كلمه
صوتيه للمتحدث الرسمي باسم التنظيم على
التليجرام ابو عمر المهاجر قال في تسجيل
صوتي ان زعيم التنظيم ابو الحسن الهاشمي
القرشي قتل اثناء المعارك دون ان يذكر
المكان او الزمان او الظروف وبشكل سريع
وفي الاعلان ذاته كشف المتحدث عن اسم
الزعيم الجديد وهو ابو الحسين الحسيني
القرشي ودعى عناصر التنظيم الى مبايعته
اذا انكشفت التنظيم عنه داعيا اعضاءه
لمبايعته في مايو الماضي ترددت انباء عن
القاء القبض على ابو الحسن القرشي واسمه
المعروف هو زيد العراقي خلال عمليه امنيه
نفذت في اسطنبول وتولى ابو الحسن قياده
التنظيم بعد مقتل زعيمه السابق ابو
ابراهيم القرشي بعمليه ام امريكيه على
الاراضي السوريه في الثالث من فبراير
الماضي سبق ذلك مقتل مؤسس التنظيم ابو بكر
البغدادي في اكتوبر من عام 2019 وعرف عن
الزعيم الرابع لداعش ابو الحسن الذي اعلن
عن مقتله اليوم بانه استاذ داعش لتوله
امور التعليم عندما بسط التنظيم سيطرته
على مناطق واسعه من سوريا والعراق